>> BRADY: Why do so many people hate mathematics?
>> Professor Frenkel: Very good question.
I think there are several reasons.
The problem is multi-dimensional, no pun intended.
Imagine that you had to take an art class
in which you were taught only how to paint
a fence or a wall but were never shown the
paintings of the great masters.
Would that make you an art lover?
Years later you will talk to your friends
and say "Oh my gosh!
I hated art at school, I was so bad at it."
What you would really be saying is "I was
bad at painting the fence."
And likewise with mathematics people often
say "Oh, I was so bad at math, I hate math."
but what they are really saying is "I was
bad at painting the fence."
So how do we make people realise that mathematics
is this incredible archipelago of knowledge?
If you want your kids to understand and appreciate
the beauty and power of mathematics we have
to connect it to our daily lives.
Let me give you an example.
Say you go on Amazon to buy a book and you
are immediately presented with various recommendations.
How does Amazon come up with these recommendations?
Well, there are sophisticated algorithms at
play which analyse your past choices, which
correlates you with other users who are deemed
to have similar preferences.
Then all this data is processed and you're
presented with these choices.
Now, I'm not saying that this is necessarily
a good thing but I think at the very least
we have to be aware of this.
We have to be aware of these algorithms invading
our lives, and those algorithms are based
on mathematics.
>> Brady: You and I live in houses and we
appreciate the houses we live in, it doesn't
mean we need to know how to lay bricks.
>> Professor Frenkel: That's right.
>> Brady: So why, just because we - just because
mathematics is underlying some of the technologies
in our lives, why does that mean we have to
understand it or even appreciate it?
>> Professor Frenkel: That's a very good point
and likewise people say "well, we fly airplanes
without necessarily understanding the, you
know, the physics of flight."
But there is a difference, and first of all
mathematics is part of our culture just like
literature and art and to have a fulfilling
life we have to be aware of this.
But also, because mathematics is becoming
so important in our lives there is a lot of
opportunity for misuse of mathematics and
for manipulating us by using highly sophisticated
mathematics.
There are many examples of that, global economic
crisis was to a large extent caused misuse
of mathematic models.
Which one could argue often were used by,
you know, executives of financial firms who
did not fully understand them.
What if we lived in a world in which a, say
a Wall Street executive, would not say "Oh,
I don't get this stuff but as long as it works,
it's fine."
What if in fact that person would say "OK,
tell me more about it, I would like to understand
how this model works."?
There's this great quote by a great German
mathematician Georg Cantor, said "The essence
of mathematics lies in its freedom."
But, I would augment this with the following;
where there is no mathematics there is no
freedom.
So mathematics is essential to our freedom,
to the function of our democracy.
That's why it's not just about finding out
how some things work, which you don't need
to know about because, you know, 'who cares?
As long as they work.'
I think that our ignorance can be misused
by the powers that be, and for us to be, you
know, the citizens in this brave new world,
we have to be more aware of mathematics.
We have to know and appreciate its power to
do good, but also to do ill.
>> Brady: The art world tells us we should
appreciate art more.
An English professor will say we need our
language skills improved.
Computer scientists will say we need to understand
code.
The mathematicians are telling us we should
appreciate maths, well some of the math.
[laugh]
We've only got these finite brains and only
so many hours on the planet, why do you bring
mathematics above the others?
I know you're a bit biased.
>> Professor Frenkel: Well first of all I'm
a mathematician, right?
But also, I would say that art for example,
let's take art.
So the situation was, people don't go to art
museums of course.
We know that, not everyone goes to that, not
everyone pays attention.
But at least people know that there are, there
exists museums.
If you say the word art, they don't think
about painting the fence but they think about
van Gogh and Picasso and Leonardo da Vinci.
So they know that at least, if they ... whenever
... if they have an interest they know where
to go, where to find those paintings.
Or they can go online and find those paintings,
right?
In the case of mathematics they are not even
aware of the masterpieces of great mathematicians
the way that they are aware of the existence
of masterpieces of the great artists.
Art of course is important because it speaks
about our emotions and it speaks about the
world and about ourselves.
But in a way, one can survive without art,
but one cannot survive without mathematics.
Everything is based on mathematics; it is
the language of nature.
>> Brady: Well, let's apportion some blame,
let's blame someone then.
It sounds to me like you're blaming high school
teachers?
You were saying, you know, back in our school
days they're making us paint fences instead
of showing us Picasso.
>> Professor Frenkel: Well, if I really were
to assign blame I would assign the blame to
myself and my colleagues.
Professional mathematicians.
We don't do nearly enough, exposing these
ideas to the public in an accessible way.
Often times we're not willing to come up with
good metaphors and analogies and this is how
science should be communicated.
You have to communicate science in a way that
would, you know, in a way that's creative.
That links to something people already know.
And I feel as though other scientists are
doing a much better job; physicists, biologists.
We keep talking about the solar system about
the universe, about galaxies, about atoms
and molecules, elementary particles and DNA.
Those concepts are no more complicated than
things we do in modern mathematics.
Why is it that, you know, DNA and stars and
elementary particles are part of our cultural
discourse but mathematical ideas are not?
Well, in part because we are not doing nearly
enough.
We professional mathematicians are not doing
nearly enough.
I don't blame the teachers because, you know,
they are in the precarious, really unenviable
position often times because they are, you
know, overworked and under paid and also teachers
themselves are products of the same flawed
system.
My solution is that, first of all, more mathematicians
should go out and let other people in on the
secret.
Because it's really almost like a secret and
we're almost like this elite which is sort
of keeping this secret, and I don't want that
to continue.
I want everyone in on the secret.
I want everyone to realise there is this beautiful
world out there, which is so important for
our daily lives, which possess the, you know,
unparalleled power and beauty.
We have to convey this idea; we have to find
ways to convey those ideas.
And then, you know, we have to also work through
our education system.
We also have to help teachers to learn the
necessary content and to learn how mathematics
connects with the real world, so that they
make the study of mathematics for students
more enjoyable, more fun, more interesting.
>> Brady: Why has that not happened?
It sounds so obvious.
What you've said is not like a huge conceptual
leap.
Why has this not already happened?
>> Professor Frenkel: What has it not already
happened?
Well sometimes I wonder myself, why has it
not already happened?
It's almost a conspiracy, I mean honestly,
it's almost like there's a system of mirrors
that has been created which distorts, you
know, reality.
Which does not allow most people to see what
is out there.
And let's face it, how many more things are
left to discover?
We can't be the first to discover another
continent like Columbus; we can't be the first
to step on the moon.
But what if I told you there is this beautiful
world out there and you don't even have to
travel anywhere to find it?
It's right at your fingertips.
Wouldn't you want to go and find out more
about it?
And if you do this in the right way you will
have children, you will have students, you
know, running to class!
Not away from the class but running to the
class, like "I want to know more.
I want to find out more.
I want to talk to my peers, to my classmates
about this stuff."
This is the coolest stuff in the world, that's
what it is.
>> Brady: Coolest stuff in the world?
And yet, everyone hates it?
>> Professor Frenkel: And yet everyone hates
it.
Isn't it ironic?
>> Brady: If you'd like to hear more from
Professor Frankel about his love of mathematics,
this is his book 'Love and Math'.
You can't have this one, this one's mine,
but you can get your own copy, and one of
the ways you can do that is through the sponsor
of this particular video, Audible.com.
Biggest range of audio books you can image,
and one of them is this one.
As you probably know by now you can go to
Audible.com/Numberphile and if you sign up
you can download a free book and it could
be this one, it'll be the book of your choice.
So if you're going to check them out go to
Audible.com/Numberphile and then when it comes
time to pick your free one, Love and Math.
I'm sure he'd appreciate it.